todas las transformaciones de Luffy
organizadas de la peor y más horrible
Hasta la mejor de último claramente está
el tagman es solo un Luffy gordo con
mucho hack y gordo luego está su tercera
marcha que sí está genial pero me ya
comenzando con lo sabroso tenemos a
Nightmare Luffy su cuarta marcha fue muy
esperada después de que doflamingo le
apalear a los sio Luffy durante media
saga y hasta el día de hoy se mantiene
como una de sus mejores transformaciones
pero no le gana al cl
su segunda marcha Siempre será una de
sus mejores técnicas algo sencillita así
pero increíble de ver y eso sin
mencionar los putazos que soltaba y
finalmente está el poderoso Gear Five
inmenso Flow gran poder y pues se
convierte literalmente en un Dios no sé
qué más quieres pero con el perdón de
oda su mejor forma sigue siendo el
mamadísimo snakeman estas son Solo siete
de las formas de Luffy pero en total
tiene más de 10 transformaciones
distintas Y en este video te las cuento
y